okay should we do the thing that's right
for our users or should we do the thing
that makes us money so that our business
stays afloat
[Music]
it's wednesday
i'm just making some lunch in the middle
of making
spam musubi we used to be really bad at
making sure to be actually
and then our friend taught us how to
make it right yes and he was like
it's not hard to make i don't know why
we had such a hard time i think it's
because we didn't know to buy this thing
we
and then the order of operations is also
kind of important too but
i just
fried up some spam so i just like cooked
it on both sides with oil and then i
added soy sauce and meating for salty
sweet savoriness
and then i'm about to start assembling
the first thing you do is you get nori
and then you put the thing on top and
then you fill it with a layer of rice
rice layer
and then you use this thing
and then you push it down
and then it makes
this layer
nice and flat inside
in goes
the spam and then more rice
i'm gonna go
oh and then what you actually do is you
leave it here and then
that's a good one
like this
put your hand a little like this
make it actually naughty which also
means glue
and then like that
tada last time
we've been eating noodles like every day
for lunch
which is great but i'm a little sick of
noodles right now which i didn't think
was possible but i am
so we've been going between rice and
bread
and salad for lunch
all right
wow i'm tired i just finished filming a
video about technical interviews and uh
it went well i kind of had fun with it
because it's kind of a dry topic and
i figured why not make fun wish i did
have fun but now i'm just tired
but as a reward for myself i'm going to
build this dog bed that i got from
amazon for kona because
kona's dog bed look
oh
it's falling apart and i wanted to see
if this new type of bed that i bought
is
like a good one
i did get this one
also because jarvis has the same dog bed
for his new dog by the way he has a
puppy he's so cute but anyways it's the
same bed and i was gonna build it and
see if colonel likes it this thing's
actually really light for it having an
entire pet's bed in here
i think it's just supposed to inflate
oh
here's what the bed looks like
conan come on go to bed
go to bed
go
yes good boy
good boy go to bed oh it's okay it's
okay oh he's like i want my old bed are
you just waiting to steal it from him
you are aren't you i'm gonna try it one
more time
yes good boy good boy
good boy there you go
this might be too small for you
hi
nope
i think it looks nice but it might be a
little too small for kona he likes very
roomy beds ellie do you want to try
getting in here oh i think this is yours
this is
you sized look at how much more natural
ellie looks in this bed
that's an early size bed
oh good girl
you're so cute
good morning happy friday i've got a lot
of work to finish up today
but
i did
also just get a monitor i'm doing a
video with lg
like in a few
uh weeks and they wanted me to review
the monitor so i got it today i was
gonna
hi
yes hello so yeah i'm gonna set it up
but i also
bought some new accessories for my desk
specifically uh i bought wheels like
rolling casters for these
because the other day
i set up my desk with my camera behind
it and i was like wouldn't this be
easier if i had wheels on it so i could
just wheel my desk around and then i
also got like one of these things that
you can pop into one of the hole sockets
so that becomes a charging port because
more often than not i'm like i just need
an outlet and a charger and i don't have
any more uh in my room once because
they're all charging like
this kind of stuff
and so
i'm gonna set that all up i think it's
gonna be
not a trivial amount of work but i'm not
quite ready to get started in my day yet
so
let's procrastinate together
[Music]
my room right now is unbelievably messy
like
ah
check it out
so
messy hey but the monitor is up thing
about cord management cleaning i feel
like it has to get messier before it can
get cleaner
[Music]
it's done
here is my final setup dude i'm really
happy with this i'm gonna make a video
about
the review for this once i use it a
little bit more so if you're not
subscribed please do so but i'm gonna
try using it now happy
tuesday everybody oh i just finished
lunch and man it's cold in san diego
that's why i'm like fleeced up right now
i'm actually still very cold my hands
are freezing but uh i
uh
i'm gonna get a haircut today because i
am sick of my own hair i've just been
having it tied up this whole time and
it's not even that long it's just like
it's at that really awkward length
where like it's like okay is it gonna
grow out longer or is it just gonna like
sit awkwardly on my shoulders the last
time i cut this was like when was the
last time i cut this i think i cut it in
april last time and i'm gonna go
get a haircut for the first time in two
years because every time i've cut my
hair since covets started i just cut it
myself because i was never cutting it
that short and it was easy to because i
didn't have to like
be able to see what was going on but i'm
gonna go get my hair cut probably not
gonna vlog very much there because
vlogging in public
scary very scary but i will show you
what it looks like afterwards
i
did a thing and moved my desk into my
bay window area because i got these
rolling casters
that i could put i think i showed it on
my previous vlog
um
but i can move my desk anywhere and i
have this cute little seat that ellie
usually loves
sitting on so i moved it over here and
now ellie
gets to sit right next to me slash i get
to sit right next to her while i work
which is great hello and happy wednesday
i just finished filming a video about
this very monitor i thought i'd show you
what my youtube setup looks like
actually all right so this is basically
what my setup looks like pretty dang
often if i have my computer in the back
then i'll have
one light here because i get a lot of
light from that window so i try to kind
of like bounce this light on the other
side of my face i've got a microphone
which is connected to my voice recorder
thingy and then i've got my camera and a
tripod and the camera has a battery that
connects straight into the wall
and ellie ellie is an important part of
this
whole equation she's my production
assistant that only ever sleeps man i'm
exhausted i had a really good therapy
session yesterday and i was talking to
my therapist
and we ended up talking about
like i don't know just feeling kind of
very creatively stuck specifically it's
just like this whole tension between
like okay do what you love but also
make it valuable for other people so
that
they will watch it or pay money for it
which is
very capitalistic but
i don't know i feel like that's just
like a attention that i feel frequently
even when i was in tech it's just like
okay should we do the thing that's right
for our users and our and our customers
and our employees or should we do the
thing that makes us money so that our
business stays afloat to employ all
those people
so my therapist gave me some good advice
where she was just like you know
i think you're probably trying to fight
something right now and maybe just see
what happens when you let go
which i don't know what it is that i'm
holding on to or what i'm fighting
because it's very abstract but
trying to let that flow through me today
because i think
you know it's like it's like reading a
fortune cookie or an astrology like
thing where it's like
maybe it doesn't make sense concretely
but if you
take those words to heart then it can
change how you view
your life it can change your actions
and you know this might as well keep
yourself open to the opportunity and the
possibility because you never know what
happens
or what could happen
happy
saturday everybody
about to do some home improvement
because we haven't
had the chance to do that also
we thought our bathroom was leaking so
we cut a hole up there to see
what the situation was luckily it wasn't
leaking which we only would have known
if we cut up that drywall
so now i gotta patch it which
i actually really like patching drywall
once
it gets to the mudding part
software engineer
takes on house projects
because she's older now
and she's almost 30 so she
should know how to do like this probably
[Music]
holy heck it worked
basically here's the paper here's the
hole so now i just got to plug it up
i mean
i mean it fits
it's a little too big
yeah let's let's do it let's do it
welcome to our garage where we have too
much
around here but we do have tools we do
have tools
[Music]
apparently what i'm supposed to do
this is the part that's supposed to be
very very therapeutic and if it works
it will be incredibly therapeutic
[Music]
if i'm good at this if this works out i
will put drywalling on my resume i think
drywalling really is very similar to
just like playing with play-doh sort of
thing
okey-dokey ready moment of truth
oh
my god
i
am so good at this
i did this right right
[Music]
i did it you did it was it really easy
it was so much easier than any
drywalling i've ever done but look it's
patched thank you for being here with me
with diy with muco
this is a success
pretty freaking happy about it
drywalling house projects not that scary
okay see you later
oh happy
monday everybody
oh the sun's shining through for once oh
now it's gone that was so fast
happy monday everybody i just took a
little 30 minute nap
after lunch
because i was tired
yesterday i just drank like so much
coffee that i didn't get very restful
sleep
last night so i took a little nap before
i started on my afternoon work but i
made some tea too
by the way check out this teapot that i
got
it's from quinto
um my mom and dad got it for me for my
birthday and it's just like
it's one of those beautifully elegant
products that just makes your life
better and i'm so glad i finally have a
new teapot because i've been using the
same one forever i thought i'd actually
take some time to figure out what's
inside here this is the sakuraku box and
they are the sponsor of today's video so
sakurago is a monthly subscription box
that includes 20 different snacks treats
sweets and tea pairings that get
delivered right to your door every month
i'm really excited to try this one
because sakurako is a japanese-based
company and so all their stuff comes
from japan they're all artisanal and i
feel like
i'm just gonna make a really good tea
pairing so let's look at what's inside
this is actually the november 2021 box
so if you see anything in here that you
want then make sure to order by the end
of this month october so that you'll get
it in time for the november box wow this
is so pretty this is so japanese
this postcard it's beautiful though
then it comes with a little guide book
which is in japanese book form because
it goes from
this side to this side the theme is
autumn and kyushu so i'm expecting lots
of like potato related things in here
which yes
this is like one of my actually
favorite snacks
of all time this is this thing is it i
freaking love this snack we got some pie
we got some manju we got some ooh
and really big smacks like this in here
as well this one
a potato monaco
[Music]
this is actually one of my favorite
parts of sakuraku i got a box um like a
couple of months ago and they all come
with like one really nice like japanese
wear
which sometimes it's really hard to find
stuff like this in the store or amazon
or online and stuff so it's really nice
that this kind of stuff comes with the
sakurako box actually has a monthly plan
and several pre-played plans so the plan
starts at 32.50
for bucks charging you every 12 months
they also have a limited promotion this
month and so if you use the code sake
2021 to sign up you'll get a free
japanese sake glassware thing
according to the plan that you choose
all of these snacks in here are
incredibly japanese and i've actually
never seen any of these before like i've
never seen them stock
stuff like this at the japanese
supermarket or really any market in
america or probably japan rather so make
sure to check out the link in the
description box down below to get your
very own sakura box now comes the hard
part which one do i choose
what do i want to eat
let's open this one up
um
holy
that's really good kamamoto castle under
the moon chestnut manju
smooth blend of azuki sweet beans and
chestnuts
i gotta say i do really benefit from
like
of all asian things being japanese i
think a lot of people just like japan
and so companies like this exist
and i know that like i feel very lucky
that i get to like
have these kinds of services near me
where like i can just get snacks
delivered to my door
that are japanese even without having to
go to japan
because man i miss japan i still haven't
been since covet started
and i feel like eating japanese food
touches someone like the deepest depths
of my soul so i definitely benefit from
y'all's obsession with japan
i suppose
[Music]
um